let's start with this from cnn jesse
smilet was released from jail wednesday
night after an illinois appeals court
granted an emergency motion by his
defense attorney smilet's legal team is
looking to delay his sentence and grant
him bond until their appeal of his
conviction is decided on the former
empire actor was sentenced last week to
30 months of felony probation including
150 days in jail
um
and
including some restitution as well quote
there's no room for politics in our
court system defense attorney nene uche
said in a news conference shortly after
the actor's release regardless of what
you think about this case the real
question is should black men be walked
into jail for a class four felony
that's a disgrace the attorney added
um
and uh
you get to the reason for this release
there isn't there there wasn't much
reason given
um
by the court for why they're releasing
justice millet for from prison
we know the real reason which we'll get
to in a second
as far as any reason what they what they
basically say is that uh well the appeal
is going to take a long time
and it's only 150 days in jail so uh
he'll he'll he's appealing the sentence
and by the time the appeals decided the
sentence will be over anyway so we're
just going to let him out of jail
by that logic
well i guess we're never going to send
anybody to jail again for the six month
sentences i guess are out the window now
because that's always going to be the
case that if you appeal it uh the appeal
will take longer than the sentence
so is that what that means we can't we
can't send anybody to jail for for that
amount of time
this only further affirms what what i
said immediately after the sentence was
passed down
and there were people talking about even
people who were happy that he was going
to jail were saying oh that's a pretty
harsh sentence uh you know
no it should have been much more than
that
he should have been looking at 5 10 15
years
for all the reasons that we've talked
about
given that he's given that he's
unrepentant
um
given the just sociopathic nature of the
everything that went into the
premeditation
as i pointed out many times the fact
that he was he was willing to let
innocent people take the fall for him
um all of that perjured himself on the
stand
you know was was trying to inflame
racial tensions would have been fine if
there was a if there was a riot in
chicago over this
he would not only would have been fine
with it he was he would have been happy
about it he probably was upset that
there was no riot
that's yet another thing that makes him
a victim is that people weren't rioting
over it
so you take all that consideration you
could easily justify the max prison
sentence which would have been as the
sentencing judge admitted 15 years and
he should have gotten all 15 years
and then at least they can't release him
from jail on the excuse that
the appeal will take longer than the
sentence
uh but now he's out of jail and
his defense attorney says well should we
be should we be marching should we
should we be walking black men into jail
for class four felonies
let me answer that question for you
if i could the answer is uh yes
why shouldn't we be
why shouldn't we be
walking black men into jail for class
four felonies
but the law stipulates that you can go
to jail for those kinds of crimes
now you notice the only thing that the
defense attorney is worried about is
black men so white men we can march yeah
well they can go to jail but black men
how dare we put black men
in jail
he's almost admitting
just by saying that he's almost
admitting
what we all know to be true anyway
that despite all the talk about white
privilege and everything else
there is privilege in this country
there's no question about it
there are people who are privileged in
many different ways
you know there's the basic kind of
privilege that comes with being wealthy
and having a lot of money and being
famous justice mullet has all that
there's also the privilege that comes
tied to identity there is racial
privilege there is identity-based
privilege
and it's privileged that you ex you
experience in the culture in society
by through social advantages and you
also experience it in the courtroom
but we're not giving that privilege out
to white people
unless they can claim some other
privileged identity for them now a white
person who says he's gay or trans sure
he'll get some privilege
but the reality is that jesse smallett
as a black
gay
rich famous person is almost as
privileged as you can possibly get
and that's exactly how he's gotten away
with all of this
got away with doing all of this and
getting on the stand
and perjuring himself lying to the court
for hours on end which the sentencing
judge mentioned that and pretended to be
upset about it
that's almost as privileged as you could
possibly get in our society today the
only thing that would make jesse
smellette more privileged is if he was
trans that's the one thing that's the
one
advantage the one card he hasn't played
yet yet i mean emphasis on yet
and maybe
my guess is that
now that he's out of jail
and all the legal problems are going to
be put behind him
you know the next thing that he's going
to want is he's going to want to get
back into hollywood and start starring
in films again
and i think though and i i think he'll
have no problem doing that
but if he really wants to make sure that
hollywood embraces him and he can get
his whole life back and maybe even
benefit from this in the end uh then
just come out as trans
so that's my guess in the next couple of
years jesse smilette
jesse smallett will become jessica
smallett in the next couple of years
that is my uh my my guess
maybe jesse is already a gender-neutral
name so he doesn't need to change it so
it's all it's already all set up for
[Music]
you